poet and author Margaret Atwood in her
latest work negotiating with the dead
the book grew out of a series of
lectures given by the prize-winning
novelist at the University of Cambridge
in 2000 exploring the gift of writing
through her own life and that of other
writers
it's an hour in 10 minutes
great good evening and welcome to the
less Bartos forum at the New York Public
Library my name is Betsy Bradley and
it's my great pleasure to introduce this
evening's conversation with Margaret
Atwood and Marilyn French as many of you
know this event was to have taken place
last September and I am exceptionally
grateful to both of this evening
speakers for their patience and
encouragement as we plotted and planned
how best to reschedule and I'm delighted
that you're both here tonight I'll begin
with miss Atwood Margaret Atwood is a
novelist short story writer poet and
literary critic her novels include alias
grace The Handmaid's Tale cat's-eye the
Robert bride and most recently blind
assassin for which she was awarded the
Booker Prize for 2000 blind assassin has
also been shortlisted for the 2002
impact Dublin award who is that what is
also celebrated for her collections of
short stories such as wilderness tips
bluebirds at Bluebeard's egg and other
stories and good bones as well as her
poems which includes the collections
journals of Susannah moody and mourning
in the burned house the tremendous
honesty and power of ms at was writing
which moves with confidence and elegance
from intimate scenes just sweeping
socio-political themes has garnered her
a host of awards including and this is a
very abbreviated selection trust me on
this the Chevalier de l'Ordre desire to
de letras the Commonwealth writers prize
a Medal of Honor from the National Arts
Club here in New York the Los Angeles
Times fiction award a Guggenheim
Fellowship and I like this one best the
Norwegian Order of literary merit we're
very pleased that she can be here with
us tonight and I'm also delighted to
welcome Marilyn French to the library
Miss French is a novelist and feminist
critic whose works include the women's
room a nationally best-selling novel
which has been hailed as a seminal text
or the women's movement as well as
beyond power on men women and morals her
mother's daughter and the war against
women Miss French has taught at Hofstra
University the College of Holy Cross and
Harvard University where she was a
Mellon fellow her most recent work is a
season in hell
a memoir a clear-eyed and compiled
account of her victory over cancer and
we're very glad to have her here this
evening as well at the conclusion of
their conversation our speakers will
take some questions from the audience as
you know the drill we have microphones
to the left and right at the stage and I
hope you'll use them for your questions
so that everybody can hear you and now
please join me in welcoming Margaret
Atwood and Marilyn French
we're very happy to see you're here
Margaret and I'm happy to see you
I think a lot of Americans don't realize
that Canada is a separate country I
think a lot of us think of it as a sort
of chillier the United States would you
tell us how you see Canada as a discrete
and a symbolic place
well of course just not just to begin
we're still in mourning for the Queen
Mum she's she's our Queen Mum - you may
not have known this but the Queen of
England is also the queen of Canada this
did inspire one of my friends to do a
series of portraits of our dear Queen in
her Canadian guys sated sidesaddle on a
mouse series is called Queen on a moose
so there is that that connection we are
part of the Commonwealth still such as
it is I think you'd have to go back in
in history to sort of trace it through
to see how all of this came about but in
fact I was picked up at the Minneapolis
Airport last week by somebody who
happens to be related to me I didn't
know this and how are they related
they're from Nova Scotia so they were
part of those people as my ancestors
were as well who left the United States
either just before the American
Revolution or during the American
Revolution or just after the American
Revolution at which point they were
political refugees and I sometimes like
to tease people here by saying of course
my ancestors were political refugees and
they say Oh what middle European
countries say well actually they were
from here Oh what shock horror so there
is that number too if you hear a second
language here it's most likely Spanish
if you hear a second language there it's
most likely French because a quarter of
the country is in fact francophone and
this has all kinds of ramifications
political and cultural and and having to
do with cuisine so all of those kinds of
differences I think the the ethnic makes
is somewhat different as well we say the
the Irish went to the states and the
Scots went to Canada of course some of
each went to either place but the but
you got more of the Irish and we got
more of the Scots and that is why you
had who was that guy Bing Crosby you
know
all of those Irish lullabies and and
sentimental Irish songs and we got the
guys in the kilts with the drums but
we're not responsible for Braveheart
strictly a southern invention that but
Canada has its own discreet character in
your work and particularly in certain
novels like surfacing where it's very
important the earlier ones maybe but
even in blind assassin it's it's a
special place it's it is further north
but on the other hand if you go to
Alaska you will find actually if you go
to Alaska you'll find people who say two
things one of them is we ought to be
Canadians and the other is Alaska where
the women are men and the men are
animals
well you've partly answered my next
question in our country we have a very
firm grasp of the stereotypes all
stereotypes so we know if a piece of
work is set in the south or in New
England or in Miami we know what to
expect we know what the unwritten
connotations are but when I'm reading a
Canadian novel and I read quite a few of
them since you have a lot of good
writers something set in Vancouver the
Maritime Provinces I don't know the
meanings of these places I do get the
meaning of the far north so as far as
the Alaskans are concerned I think I
probably have a pretty good grasp and of
the north part of Quebec I have some
sense from having read Marie Claire bleh
but I don't know you for instance will
sometimes have a character go from
Toronto to Vancouver what does that mean
to you going from Toronto to Vancouver
well at the time I did it it meant
getting as far away from Toronto without
actually falling into the seats it was
not I was not feeling very cozy towards
Toronto at that moment in time and I was
very happy to go to Vancouver so it was
it was the great escape and to some
extent at that time which was 1964 and
of course you always have to situate
these things in time because everything
changes as you know from decade to
decade and things shift around but at
that time it was a small it was a safe
word and there weren't very many tall
buildings and it was very into cults you
know cults of all different kinds so
visit now yes really yeah to a certain
extent things sweep through all of a
sudden everybody will do be doing
Rolfing or
this I was like California for us well
but Rainier sort of like Seattle for you
only sunnier I've been there and it's
very beautiful I didn't notice the cult
you must have been there on a beautiful
day because there can be weeks of gray
foggy rain but when I was there I was 24
years old
and the lowest person on the University
totem pole so I was so low that people
didn't even bother involving me in their
faculty fights my head so I had a good
time but I watched them all worked on me
badly behaved and I was given of course
the lowest of the low jobs and one of
those was teaching English grammar to
engineering students at 8:30 in the
morning and a Quonset hut I still had
coins that Hut's they hadn't was that
close to the war but we got on quite
well we were all asleep that was fine
and I taught them Kafka I had them do
little imitations of kaif comparables
nice and short contained a puzzle they
liked that part and they could do that
and I've always felt that it must have
been a help to them in their future
lives
I'm sure wonder if any of them ever
tried to build that machine that itches
your sin upon your body well in some
version or another they may have done
that the penal colony which I've always
thought is a novel way of teaching
reading because the sentence got
engraved on you until finally there was
a moment of enlightenment after which
you died
reviewers it seems to me both men and
women almost never find a woman's novel
political with the exception of The
Handmaid's Tale and may be edible woman
I don't remember the reviews for edible
women so I don't know I'll tell you
about them they never refer to the
politics in your novel how do you feel
about that well some of them do but
unfavorably AHA and others do some but
when the things first come out of course
that's that those I suppose would be the
reviews I wrote the end of a woman in 64
in this very same Vancouver on
University of British Columbia exam
booklets you know those exam booklets
with the lines
well one booklet per chapter and then
the publisher lost the Canadian
publisher lost for four years or so
which is why it didn't come out until
1969
so between 64 and 69 there was a sea
change namely that which had been read
only in the bathroom such as The
Feminine Mystique and the second sex and
not admitted to at parties suddenly
became something you can discuss and
was this the women's movement and I
remember when the women's movement began
because I was in Edmonton Alberta or I
can tell you there was no women's
movement but people were still still
wearing white socks and wedgies not
because they'd come back into style
I had a vet bad two years but a friend
of mine in New York wrote me and told me
about this thing and sent me that
article which you will remember called
house workers work okay then
the Edible women came out in 1969 and it
was revered by two kinds of people those
who had heard of the women's movement
having begun and those who had not and
those who had not said this was a novel
by a young writer who was confused and
would mature later and come to her into
her right mind develop a more mature
attitude and the ones who had or on the
other hand made rather nervous by it
so I also had my first interviews at
that time which included an interview in
which somebody asked me however did I
manage to write and did the housework to
at the same time
which point I said look under the bed
for the giant monster dust bunny is
living and another man who said quite
famously in a nervous way do men like
you I said ask them I don't know which
men that later modulated into do you
like men and which point I said the same
thing which men not too fond of Hitler
Albert Schweitzer on the other hand is
quite nice
so that all of that began right then and
I also did my first book signing ever it
was for some reason I've never that's
never become clear to me it really was
in the men's silk and underwear
department of the Hudson's Bay Company
in Edmonton Alberta
it was the publicists first week on the
job I don't know why they put it there
but there I was with my table and a
little stack of edible women smiling
hopefully at all of the guys who were
coming in to buy their underwear and
socks at lunchtime how many did I sell
to a lot of a lot of nervous galoshes
footed scuttling the other way you
remind me of a British journalist who
came to interview me once she picked me
up at I was at my hairdresser he cut my
hair in his apartment his apartment had
never been dusted I don't know how long
he'd lived there but many many years but
it was very elaborate and beautiful and
rich but it was very dusty then she came
back to my apartment which is very very
clean I got two reviews in this one
review one was this filthy dusty
hairdressers apartment and second was
this disgustingly clean my apartment
they said I don't know what kind of
grade I got on housework well I don't
let them into the house anymore and the
reason it let them into the house among
other things never minds of breakfast
dishes but some of the furniture in it
is actually Graham's grandfather's
furniture and I do not wish to have
because they do review your furniture
and think that it means some things
about your personality
and I don't really wish to come out with
the personality of this dead old man who
lived 19th century so I just don't let
them in I let them in sometimes if
they're from foreign countries and once
had a French one and we sat in the
backyard and the first and only time it
ever happened a groundhog ran across the
lawn and he was thrilled but the other
time I let a British one into the
backyard this is quite bad it was the
robber bride a somewhat gothic work no
it was alias grace even worse and there
he was and there was the sick Robin
that hadn't flown into a window or
something and Graham emerged from a
shrub somewhere and found this robin
lying on the lawn and he did what you
and I would do or maybe you wouldn't you
you have to collapse their lungs by by
squeezing gently if you if you cannot
bring them back to health
you must dispatch them quite quickly and
that was the way to do it so he did this
and here's this British journalist
watching so the beginning of the
interview is from the shadows strangling
a
from the British who build tunnels
across their roads so that the toads can
get across you know he was being
mischievous as well we know and they
will do that given any opportunity so
how do you feel about not being called
political well you know I am called
political quite a bit in Canada they
think I'm sort of red red Emma you know
was various other people thrown in paint
not because of particularly women
although if you go back into the 70s a
lot of it is about that and but it but a
lot about positions I've taken about
about Canadian politics of various kinds
uh-huh but that's an interviews
interviews in reviews political young
political there they do that to there
they even do it some and in England I
think there and to do it less here
because political has two meanings one
is it's about Washington you know the
political novel is about politicians and
what they do and it's like Benjamin
Disraeli Sybil you know that's a
political novel it's about politics and
the way they all go about it and the
other meaning is the person has opinions
you know it's not just entertainment and
in any country other than the United
States if you're talking with young
writers and ask them why they write in
things whatnot whatnot other places in
the world they will usually come out
with an answer that has to do with their
relationship to their society in some
form or another here they're more likely
to say it's
for me it's for my soul it's for my
inner individual and self-expression its
individual I think what I'm getting at
here is how in general feminism is not
seen as a political stance which i think
is very strange when now not review us
so much as literary critics discuss
political novels they usually mean
socialists they don't see feminism as a
political stance how did they say it
here as a pain in the neck pain in the
neck they see it that way there are two
but but with add-ons and there is
prisons in Quebec Quebec had a very
strong feminist movement that might
surprise you but they came out of a
situation in which they were very very
dominated by them by the church and
suddenly in the sixties that all just
went poof and it was in the early 60s
and a lot of these very strong feminists
came from families in which the mother
had had 16 kids you know and they've
grown up and living without and being
expected to do that and they were just
saying no we're not going to live our
lives that way we've seen it and they
were much stronger than they've been the
Anglophones in that way so there are
some surprises
it depends partly also where you were in
the world what this the feminism thing
means for instance I was in India and I
was talking to some some women and they
said we have no interest whatsoever in
any kind of thing that says you can't
wear makeup or pretty sarees there any
of that kind of thing we aren't
interested in that what we are
interested in is getting jobs for very
poor women which gives them dignity
within the family more autonomy than
they had have ever had so they were not
interested in the decorative our
side of any of that they were interested
in the economic side and I think here a
stereotype was created which said
feminists are people who don't have any
sense of humor we've all heard that life
lightbulb joke what was you've never
heard the like button I don't know how
many feminists does it take to change a
lightbulb that's not funny
or you know you have to wear overalls or
you know all of those kinds of things or
that what it means is you can't ever say
bad things about women because you have
to have the Solidarity and that means
actually ignoring real life quite a bit
because I don't know about you but not
every woman that I have ever known has
been an angel of light
they have their little quarters that
often broken the taboo the heroines well
yes heroines have to be sweet and
lovable I mean even if they're nasty or
even if they're prostitutes you really
have to find them appealing and then you
go write something like alias grace I
thought she was quite appealing but then
I'm very appealing to me but I have
curious tastes well I think women are
people and that is the fundamental but
that's where I take my stand women are
people they shouldn't be expected to be
more angelic than anybody else nor
should they be expected to be you know
last Hume and then other than those
other kinds of people
they're they're human beings with a
twist but they're human beings and you
Marilyn you are just a little bit older
than me so you probably got you probably
actually had a more horrible time than I
did well we could compare but well I
think probably because talking to people
who were coming of age you know in the
late forties not a lot of fun
do you remember generation of vipers
well well I mentioned it recently in an
interview is saying that outcomes these
books generation of vipers and he wrote
another one Phillip Wiley what was the
other I don't remember the name of it
but what his thesis was was American men
were being destroyed they were all being
turned into homosexuals and it was all
their mother's fault then of course
shortly after that mother's cause
schizophrenia and mothers caused autism
mothers caused just about every disease
there was women throng to buy these
books which I I read them you read them
I did I wanted to find what was wrong
with us oh yes and how you could fix it
now I know now you know well I I on the
other hand grew up in a has the hold of
scientists of I was reading books called
things like rats lice and history
about plagues so although we are
interested in what was wrong with things
where we had a very broad view what was
wrong with everything does women a
political or a feminist writer almost
has it seems to me to write in her novel
a running commentary on the literature
of the past and you do that terrifically
and all the time care to discuss that a
little bit hmm
I'd never actually thought about it but
of course if you read a lot you're very
conscious of what you call people in
your books what their names are
for instance and also if you go back far
enough you can say that the styles of
heroine change the styles of hero
changed as well but the heroines changed
as in painting really quite a lot
they changed quite radically from age to
age you'd be interested to know also
that styles in women's first names are
much more changeable than styles in
men's first names right people who study
these things and count them I don't know
it's not the literature of the past is
without feisty heroines somebody wrote a
very good pace on unchaste
in which he or she and I forget which it
was was talking about the fact that in
Chaucer you get everything you know you
get all kinds of women you get all kinds
of language you've got all kinds of
stories and then something shot down
first of all they started censoring
literature once they once it began to be
printed in printing presses censorship
stepped in and they censored clays
before
which is why there is so little actual
swearing in Shakespeare religious
wearing was not permitted but that Wife
of Bath kind of character you know
living her life financially independent
quite raucous rather disrespectful very
forthright in her manner of expression
that disappeared from literature
probably until about the 20th century
because the law has changed making the
Wife of Bath impossible
she couldn't own her own property about
two but also people were less likely to
write about her except as you know
forget the economic side but except has
a secondary character a kind of Dickens
funny person or in England if you are
very rich and you happen to have
inherited in a certain way it could be
Miss Havisham yeah she owned her own
property only because she never married
you gotta when I talk about you using
literature of the past I don't mean you
do a kind of deconstructive use of say
Dickens or whatever I mean you include
many different genres with which women
especially those with which women are
associated like romance in your novels
as a kind of collage you use different
kinds of literature I feel you're
commenting on those literature's but
maybe you you're you have another
intention I think you can't help but be
commenting on them if you it is like a
collage and that's exactly what a
collage does it takes one kind of
representation and sticks it on the
canvas and puts another kind of
representation over and around the first
one and then it puts a frame around it
and so each kind so if you glue
newspaper on to canvas and then paint on
it the painting and the and the
are both a representation of reality but
they're very different and they both
cancel out each other and comment on
each other so you've got two levels of
reality going on at the same time
somebody else who does this although and
not a very obvious way as is Alice
Monroe in her book the lives of girls
and women because in each of those
chapters in the in the book the young
girl is reading something reading some
kind of print you know it might be
something like the National Enquirer or
it might be romance and she gets at the
library or it might be the musical that
they're putting on at school and for a
while she wonders whether that is
reality and whether that is reality and
then something happens in real life that
that undercuts it but doesn't cancel it
out both of the things exist at the same
time it's very interesting to watch that
and at the end the young girl is writing
her own first novel which has a young
girls first novel with many extremes and
it is called the photographer and the
photographer comes to town and he's
quite sinister and he takes pictures of
people and the people of whom he takes
the pictures have sinister things happen
to them after that and when the pictures
are developed all of their eyes are
blank and the young girl of course
thinks this is a wonderful new literary
thing that but it ends with her as an
adult making lists making lists of real
things so I think I think what we're
coming around to is what is it when
you're writing fiction are you
representing reality are you going into
the life of the imagination
how do those things overlap if you
imagine yourself as a helpless heroine
on the run are you going to become one
on the other hand if you imagine
yourself as Scarlett O'Hara tearing down
the curtains and making them into an
evening gown and saying tomorrow is
another day it's not gonna give you
fortitude these are open questions but I
think people do tend to and it's not
just books it's women's magazines it's
what you're seeing on the television you
are always well you read Philip Wylie
you're always comparing yourself with
representations of how other people
think you are or ought to be and does
this relate to your use of myth and
archetype in your work it's something
I've always found fascinating my
position and in relation to all of this
comparing and things is that I grew up
outside it I grew up up north
my mother was in no way interested in
any of the things I'm just described oh
she loved being up north because there
are no vacuum cleaners there was no
electricity team or trousers all the
time she wanted something to eat for
dinner she went down to the dock and
caught a fish you know this was not tea
parties it was not the social life it
was not urban it was none of those and I
wasn't really brought up in a way that
said little girls must do this little
boys on the other hand did that so that
when I encountered all of this and
people's ideas most of the time I just
thought they were bizarre it was
anthropology my high school was like any
of my friends and I too when we reached
an age where we were supposed to behave
like adults did not have any idea what
it meant to be a woman because we were
not Rhea
by mothers who insisted that we wear
white gloves to dinner and so forth
my friend read women's magazines I'm
wondering if you did women's magazines I
relied to learn how to be a woman that's
what she talked oh well I read true
trash magazines well I thought they were
hilarious
they were supposed to be a read women's
magazines they puzzled me quite a lot
because it wasn't the age when there
were a number of things you couldn't
print including the true nature of
products that you were advertising so
one of my most surreal moments as a
child was the mode S note question a
woman in an evening gown used to have
three little dolls in descending order
and I would say I'd be fascinated by
these dolls and I'd say mom what are
those dolls for what is this product
what is this never mind I don't know I
don't know well the mode s ads were
women very glamorous women rather
surrealist looking with floating
draperies
bluesy in the background really
fascinated and all it said was mode s
dot dot dot because so
because what and then there were excuse
me the Kotex heads and they were quite
interesting because they told little
stories they were told little stories
about social situations who might
encounter that might be difficult such
as what do you do when you go to the
prom and and your hands are glowing your
hands are sweaty
do you wear gloves put talcum powder on
them wipe them on your date's jacket or
what and they're little squares that you
could check and the fourth one was
always about this product that nobody
would say what it was and it was for
those days I had no idea what those days
were and you know you couldn't find out
any more than you couldn't put the word
rape in the newspaper then so you had
read these strange pieces of journalism
what you would say the woman was found
murdered in her head was some distance
from her body but she had not been
interfered with
but in any way that matters
what is going on in adult life and I I
said I read the word child molester in
the newspaper I had no idea how to
pronounce that I had the same problem
with an enemy nominee Anatomy I still
like it alone yeah well I said child
molester I thought that they it was a
job that kids can have the head to do
with catching moles
in the other ther of people who caught
worms you know like you can see them at
night if you're in the right place but
so I thought these other people caught
in moles but and that and that you could
because I had jobs quite early in life I
thought that maybe this might be a
potential anyway you live and learn the
other one I remember was the Lysol ad
which was a Chotu pool and a woman with
her arms up like this in a very dramatic
way and it said drowning in a sea of
hysteria doubts and ignorance you you
missed that one Pete you're a little
later than I I the other one I loved was
the mother and her two children looking
out at the rain a rainy dark and stormy
night and it said are your loved ones
safe tonight and it was an adverb a
concrete coffin enclosing vault
we has to be given magazines when we
were ill you know that's what you got
you got magazines the scissors the paste
and the scrapbook that's how I saw all
of these things you were all before your
time James Joyce always said that in the
20th century you can't write about love
or love is not the great drama that it
once was but that it gains something in
a me ability I agree with him that in
that I think love stories are no longer
possible so I was very happy when I read
the blind assassin and absolutely
believed the love story and loved it do
you think it's because of taboo I think
love stories of the classic kind which
usually meant drama disappointment and
death of some sort that kind there has
to be a barrier of course so you can't
have that kind unless there's the
barrier but when you read the newspapers
you find that these kinds of things are
still going on really quite a bit we did
go off to to see Titus Andronicus the
play and I did go with with Alice Monroe
and she said at the beginning as we were
going in she said I've never been to
this and I said neither vine and she
said I've been reading it she said
surely it's meant to be a farce
and so we went in Paul said I don't
think so I don't think it's supposed to
be funny so we went through the first
act and we staggered out into the night
to have our ice cream bar and she said
it's not meant to be funny she said it's
like the National Enquirer
these things still go on the question is
how do you make the mint of literature
that's the problem without being a
parody of some kind or or being just
silly and that is that is a problem try
to send dronicus quite makes it no I
know not as a love story or not as no
does anything well it has a certain no
you're right it doesn't but but it was
surprisingly well performed on the other
hand if you could if you could stomach
it's horrible the blind assassin is
written from many different perspectives
the first person memoir is a set of
objective reportage there is a
third-person story about a love affair
which is written from two perspectives
of male one and a female one and within
the love affair there's a another piece
of fiction about other people told from
an objective standpoint
tell us why all these refractions exist
when in fact the entire novel is about
one woman well it gets back to collage
but it also gets back to telling telling
who is telling what and when you have
somebody telling you always have
somebody that they're telling it to
either it's deer Raider
you know deer Raider you alone will
share my thoughts
or somebody within the story is telling
it to somebody else within the story and
when my person called iris chase Griffin
who is 82 begins to tell what she has
never told before she's never told she
doesn't know who she's telling to and
part of the novel is her discovery of
the person that she feels needs to hear
this because it does the I think any
novel is an ancient mariner situation no
the the ancient mariner is seized with
with the need to tell and he can
recognize the person who needs to be
told so there's that connection and of
course what you always hope when you're
a writer is that you write the book you
published in the book you send it out
and that person who needs the story will
find it that's what you hope and
sometimes that does happen in fact it
probably happens quite a lot but you
never know that it has happened you
never know
so she's finding out who she needs to
tell to the newspapers and magazine
clippings which are quite short position
her position the story very quickly in
time because this is a person now of 82
years of age that's a long time you
can't do every year it would be a very
long book if you did that so we can jump
a bit using that technique and we can
also show what events were going on at
the time which were quite dramatic
events she lives through the First World
War the twenties the depression in the
Second World War
those are the events that are that
shaped the reality that we're still
living with now those newspaper
clippings were genuine weren't they the
newspaper clippings could not be genuine
really because
the people in them are fictional but the
newspapers are real and that is exactly
the kind of thing they go on about
because you captured the tone so
completely in those clippings that they
set the moral universe of the novel in
instantly you didn't have to do anything
more you did more but you didn't have to
a very brilliant device well thank you
the newspapers of themselves were not
always amused the Toronto Star whatever
world event is going on it has to have
some relation to street repairs in
Toronto for instance what's the meaning
of the title of the blind assassin the
blind assassin well now the blind
assassin is wait we have a no pulp
science fiction writer who was the young
man and the story and this is quite al
kharid you could make a living if you
could write very quickly under different
names writing for the pulps in the 30s
he is telling in order to keep her
attention
he's the Scheherazade in Reverse he's
he's spinning out a tale to the woman
with whom he is in love they can only
meet in secret so he has a different
installment at each meeting she is the
person who is susceptible to narrative
so he's doing essentially what a fellow
does at the beginning of that play he
tells and he tells the tale that holds
her attention and the tale that he tells
is about a blind assassin the assassin
has become blind because on the planet
Zichron where all of this is taking
place this tale that he has invented the
children weave carpets the child's
slaves
weave carpet
and because they weave carpets at such
an early age it makes them go blind
people think I make stuff up Marilyn no
I don't make up almost hardly anything I
got that out of the National Geographic
every one of those little devices
invented to humiliate women actually
existed at some point they've all been
done
they've all been done and even a lot of
the other devices not invented to
humiliate women been invented to
humiliate other people they've been done
- yeah
so human history is a big grab bag of
improbabilities which have nevertheless
happened and read the newspaper I often
say to people who don't believe you know
think I I have a grotesque and twisted
imagination you know they just they
don't read the papers right you just
have a better memory they probably try
to forget I also tear things out of of a
clipping spa my last question and we've
discussed this other times do you
believe in evil do I believe in evil do
I believe in a person with pointy ears
the new tail and horns well no but I
believe in evil yes of course you see it
man of well again of course you see it
manifested oh you see evil things
happening all the time
and you know I believe in it and you do
and I think this is really interesting
so you don't believe that it's evil you
think it's just a kind of mistake I I
think that yes I think it's a kind of
mistake I don't think anybody intends
evil ever Marilyn
they do I'm gonna tell you an
interesting thing that I read in the
newspaper it's a man who was doing an
experiment along these lines and he
devised a game that you can play and in
this game you can gain money you know
like monopoly pretend money and you can
then deprive other people of the money
that they have gained but you have to
sacrifice some of your own money that
you have gained in order to do that and
two-thirds of the players will do that
rather than say the other person have it
they will they will sacrifice their own
in order to make the other persons
disappear and you don't think that
they're convinced they're doing
something good they're not convinced
they're doing something good no there is
well it's an argument we'll go on having
but I wish you would tell me what you
think the nature of evil is I think I
know okay the nature of evil well a
surprising thing to me is that you're
more optimistic than I am I always have
thought it would have been the other way
but I don't think it's optimism I get
maybe I have a you know I really believe
that we have to be grateful to all the
fuck-ups in the world because it's human
helplessness and mistakes and
carelessness and inefficiency that is
responsible for the fact that we're
still a year because if these guys set
out who set out to conquer the world had
been efficient the world would have
disappeared a long time ago I think
that's probably true so I see it more as
a set of mistakes and good intentions
gone into insanity
that's maybe I could say I believe in
Richard the third
even though Richard the third we know
the real Richard was there it wasn't
like that but but when Richard the third
on the stage speaks I believe him when
he says watch me just because I was
built this way I'm gonna wreck things
for everybody else I don't believe it
for a minute um not just because he's
built that way but because he's envious
that's it
so maybe evil comes down to an v and
there isn't there's a wonderful book
about a man who studied as a Western
psychiatrist he was from India and then
he went back to India and looked at the
things that they did there for people
with various sorts of problems such are
quite different and involved shamanism
and you know sacrificing at the temple
of mice and things like that and there's
one culture there which if somebody
falls sick in the village they believe
that it is because somebody else in the
village is envious of them and what you
have to do is find the person who is
envious and appeased them make them feel
less envious and then the sick person
will get better but just to conclude on
evil I highly recommend the first
intimate film that has ever been made
it's in an octa tuk
it's called at an orgy at the fast
runner it's epic in proportion it's a
knockout it's got a grandmother in it
whom you will like and it begins with
evil arriving and to know what it says
it says it came from the north
we don't know why
that's what marina what's-her-name
know her name's not marina the woman who
wrote on the anthropologist who wrote on
the European civilizations of 10,000 BC
they were mattress centric they were
idyllic there was no war they were no
there was no killing and then they came
from the north those are all my
questions Margaret Marilyn thank you so
much thank you
you audience questions you can just come
to the microphones we'll take a few
questions now
I'm one of the minority of men here and
I had a recent argument quite a bitter
argument Sydney what are you saying
Tereus
it's okay okay anyway I had a recent
argument with a bitter argument with my
wife and we looked up books our aside
wife killing and then we want to see
what was the comparable word for husband
killing and we couldn't find it so if
you had can shed any light on that let
me know if the question was they'd had
an argument with his wife and they
looked up the word for wife killing
which was X or assigned and they looked
to see if there was a comparable word
for a husband killing and they could not
find one there is one it's called
treason
I'm quite serious because Shakespeare
uses it husband killers tend to be slow
poisoners so maybe not quite so dramatic
a thing hi I must preface my question by
saying that I'm a great fan of your work
miss Atwood and in particular the
Handmaid's Tale which I read two months
ago and it was an interesting time to
read it two months ago because two
months ago was post September 11th
post the establishment of the Patriot
Act which among many things sort of
conveyed the notion that any of us could
be watched at any time for any reason
all the time and amidst discrimination
against Arabs and severe media
manipulation and I so I was shocked by
The Handmaid's Tale I thought it was so
interesting and so relevant and because
of the similarities that I found between
its its content and your ideas and
actual contemporary American society so
I was wondering if you could comment on
the relevancy that you see between your
ideas and and you know American society
within the the last few months and also
whether or not you intended your
portrayal of future a future us to be
read as realistic or not well no
any society when it's threatened and
thrown into turmoil has a tendency to
trade off individual freedom for safety
and control but I've not been the first
person to write about this when I was 14
aprox or maybe a little younger than
that I read 1984 which had just come out
at that time and that too is a dystopia
and that too involves total surveillance
and mind control and and those kinds of
things but this is a recurring motif in
human history the most potent
combination is the combination of
religion and politics because then if
you object you're not just a dissident
you're a heretic and then you get burned
at the stake and if you've looked at all
into the doings of the Inquisition and
how things went on in those days or even
into the history of which burning and
what-have-you
people get possessed I mean they really
do get possessed by a sort of frenzy
that they project evil onto other people
and they feel that they have to stamp it
out and I'm a student of the Salem
Witchcraft Trials among other things
they happen to be near the Canadian
literature in the Widener Library at
Harvard so and also I had a relative
involved but they went through all of
that and then they realized that they've
been had you know that they'd been had
that they'd been of the victims of a
mass hysteria and they killed a lot of
innocent people and one of the Divine's
talking about this said we we were
indeed visited by the devil but not in
the way that we thought
so what you always must try to do under
those circumstances is is keep your head
you know not gettin swept away
however the middle position is the most
most vulnerable one because you can be
shot out by both sides
I did notice how how hot-to-trot mr.
Robinson mr. Robertson mr. Falwell were
at that moment you know visitation of
God fault of the feminists fault of the
American Civil Liberties yeah but think
of it if they had had takers for that
position just think of it absolutely and
I think one of the points of my little
fable was don't get too secure because
anything can happen anywhere given the
conditions and don't let us not believe
that we are all somehow exempt from this
kind of behavior in this kind of
reaction because because we're not so
did I intend it to be realistic yes and
no I it begins with a quote from
Jonathan Swift Modest Proposal a famous
piece of writing in which he proposed
the solution to the Irish problem which
would be marketing babies for the
purposes of cooking them and he wasn't
you know this was heavy irony but after
some people believed thought it was
actually quite a good idea and you do
you do have to be you have to watch out
for that when you're writing social
satire so the the costumes of the Econo
wives no I didn't mean not to be
realistic though you never know the the
general pattern we can do those kinds of
things
and if somebody says that that's what
they want to do give them the power and
they'll do it so if they're saying women
should be back in the home give them the
power how are they going to get those
women back into the home all those women
running around using ATM machines and
getting up to all kinds of shenanigans
how are you going to get them back into
the home are you gonna just deprive them
of the things that they have won over a
very short period of time really you're
gonna do it the Taliban did simple
you can't own money you can't own
property you can't have a job you can't
go outside you're in the home in
addition I just wanted to say that it
was interesting to hear you say that
your work within the u.s. is usually
characterized as unpolitical and you
know a sort of personal agenda and
therapeutic type of thing because it
seems a very easy way to dismiss your
the validity of your ideas as something
that just applies to you war has come
from your imagination rather than
something that actually affects everyone
can't hear okay enough time thank you I
had a question you mentioned India a
couple of times and someone who's from
India had mentioned to me that there are
towns were they are kidnapping women
because of the problem of letting their
female children die so that they should
have more sons and so there are towns
that only have sons who now have no one
to marry how is it that a mom in like
China or and do you have an
understanding of that and I
one can let their female children just
die and the second question is is there
anything that we can do about I mean
that were you or someone can do about
that I just don't understand it's it's
it's economic it's driven by economics
and how they how the arrangements how
the economic arrangements go on in India
with the dowry system the the father is
responsible for providing a dowry for
each daughter that gets married so any
economist will then tell you that a
daughter represents a net economic loss
whereas the Sun represents a net
economic gain to the family and unless
you rearrange that you are going to have
those kinds of feelings that that well
marilyn is actually Marilyn probably
knows a lot about this something we
didn't mention is that Marilyn has a
book coming out the first volume is
being published in May it's called from
eve to dawn and it is the history of
women through the ages and the first
volume I bet you anything is gonna deal
with some of these matters you know how
did it become that way how did it become
how did the situation arise in which
women represented a net economic loss
and men represented a net economic gain
because that sure ain't like that in
hunting gathering societies so that's
just I mean it's a huge a huge problem
to be discussed Marilyn's gonna say
something about it
well actually kidnapping is not a
problem in India it's a problem in China
where actually you know that according
to nature something like a hundred and
four boys are conceived to every hundred
girls and something like a hundred boys
are born
to every 98 girls but by the time
they're a year old the sexes are equal
because in other words boys are more
vulnerable for some reason in in places
like India and in places like the United
States and most of the Western world
women comprise 51% of the population
just because of this little
vulnerability in the male but in places
like India and certain Arab countries
because they either kill girl babies or
malnourished them the the statistics are
now about 48 women to 50 men in China at
least the proportion has dropped so
greatly that men can't find wives and
that's why they kidnap women and that's
a big problem there I don't know what
what the statistics are throughout China
but in certain places there are simply
not enough women to marry the men and
the you know most of us think of
marriage is something you do for
companionship and sex but in most of the
world
marriage is an economic arrangement and
women do all the work and that's why
every man wants a wife because she keeps
him alive she works so hard
and that's true in gathering societies
where women produce 80% of the food to
kill women is again a stupidity that
results in an evil but I don't know who
who thought this what you can do about
it is get involved I mean there are lots
of lots of organizations that work on
these things if you care and you know if
you have the heart to care then use it
Thanks
on earth on a different subject from
feminism one of the many things I admire
in your writings is your seemingly at
least easy comfortable familiarity with
science and scientific concepts and
illusions and not just the kind of
woman's science not just biology and
anthropology and those Sciences but
physics and cosmology and so forth could
you tell me a little bit about that well
known I was I actually got better marks
in science and in my high school
graduating exams which were the
equivalent of university entrance exams
and the reason for that was that they
took half a mark off in the English
exams for a spelling mistake and I was
not a good speller so I could spell
words like scruffy Larry ACI
but I couldn't spell words like weird
bees and the eyes and those things I
fell down on them I was brought up in a
family in which my father was a an
entomologist and my brother was a writer
as I was and a scientist a science
interested person as I was but the paths
diverged in the yellow wood and he
became a neurophysiologist and I became
a writer but I retained my interest in
science and he retained his interest in
writing and reading in fact the first
book I published he he read through the
edible woman and sent me a copy with all
the typos sparked
so I just I like to keep up with it and
I've got other relatives my nephew is a
physicist and we're into the 11
dimensions these days and so every time
I say him I say how's the universe any
changes he brings me up to date my other
nephew ISM is a materials engineers
specializing in crystal modeling on
computers and his companion is a
forensic anthropologist pretty
interesting stuff she is to have a pet
her father is a bat biologist and
because of all these that interests I'm
also somewhat involved in conservation
kinds of things both here and in some
other countries so I read you know it's
kind of mind candy for me I I don't get
into the heavy numbers but I just like
to keep up I enjoy it in other words
market Attwood is the author of The
Handmaid's Tale the blind assassin and
Anna's pet her latest work is called
negotiating with the dead it's published
by Cambridge University Press for more
information visit CU p